une manifestation sur les trottoirs sans
entraver la circulation
coli sur un cercueil des images de
visages et de courbes laisser des photos
de gilet jaune d'autres villes de france
dont les manifestants dijonnais se
sentent solidaires flash ball c'est
vraiment une arme redoutable on a 18
personnes à bord ni aujourd'hui on a en
1700 blessés je crois au total plus de
200 grands blessés des gens et des mains
arrachées
voilà donc ça suffit qu'ils arrêtent de
nous massacrer est ce qu'ils sont en
train de massacrer à plein de gens vous
pourrez filmer le cercueil qui a plein
de gens qu'ils ont perdu des bras des
mains des yeux et caetera et que c'est
pas normal sur internet david dufresne
un journaliste vérifie et compile des
images de manifestants blessés selon lui
357 signalements dont 160 blessures à la
tête
souvent cité comme responsable le lbd40
un flash-ball améliorée mais pour les
policiers pas question de remettre en
cause son usage l'indispensable parce
qu'il permet aux unités de maintien de
l'ordre de rester à distance vraiment de
fait vraiment délictueux et dangereux en
décembre dernier nous vous parlions du
cas de ce jeune dijonnais de 15 ans
atteint d'une double fracture à la
mâchoire
il est l'une des quatre personnes à
avoir porté plainte à dijon une
procédure est classée sans suite et
trois sont toujours en cours comme
toutes les armes c'est ce sont des
hommes qui présente une dangerosité pour
l'instant je n'ai pas constaté de
d'attraction de la part des forces de
l'ordre ce que j'ai vu tout cas celle
pour laquelle je me suis prononcé il n'y
avait pas à mon sens d'une infraction
pénale
parmi les légendes présents hier soir
certains n'hésitez pas à parler d'une
justice à deux vitesses plus prompt à
condamner lorsqu'il s'agit des
manifestants pas de chiffres à notre
connaissance sur ces condamnations le
parquet ne l'ait révélera que ce jeudi